[Applaudissements]
parce que j'étais au pied des montagnes
et je me suis dit que ça serait bien de
monter au sommet des montagnes de savoir
les descendre rapidement au les
médailles olympiques
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
deux médailles de bronze olympique et ce
sont des événements qui sont graves et
la dernière la médaille de bronze aux
jeux à nagano en 98
bon c'était le seco dernier mais c'est
une médaille en descente la discipline
reine je suis concerné par
l'environnement
est ce que j'aimerais c'est que le sport
soit encore plus plus solidaires au
niveau de l'environnement et fassent des
efforts aussi montre l'exemple pour pour
les jeunes générations